[Musique]
cette fois voici du nouveau mari qui
était la ville lumière est aujourd'hui
la ville par le métro qui laissait
naguère aux narines délicate or
regrettable souvenir est devenu suhard
et odorant chaque rame comportera
bientôt un pulvérisateur qui répondra au
cours de son voyage au nuage parfumée
[Musique]
la station lille apporte vraiment son
nom la station jasmin possède c'est vrai
caractère juif et bel-air n'est plus un
vain mot et il n'est pas dit que nous
anticipions en prévoyant telle scène
pour montmatre s'il vous plaît prenez la
direction ma griffe changer l'histoire
de paris et descendez à mitsouko mais
dans certains cas quelle tranquillité
mais d'où viens tu qu'est ce que c'est
que ce parfum mettront beaucoup
[Musique]